speaking of batmobiles let's look at
that tesla doing a [ __ ] oh my god
is that the most viral video of the last
year yeah so the dude alex choi is like
a car creator
[Music]
i don't know if that's the best way to
put it he's got a youtube channel and he
creates like a lot of car content a lot
of crazy [ __ ] honestly so he hosted a
tesla meet i think he's got a couple
cars and and so he's got like this baby
blue tesla
and so a bunch of people you know they
all meet up they're going for a drive
just for shits and giggles at exactly 10
o'clock click the fart noise you know
what it's actually actually
then he said this dude pulls up and he
just kind of tells everyone to just pull
over and park i didn't hear the story so
everyone just pulls over in the park and
alex his youtube video about it is
[ __ ] nuts man he's got so many
different angles of this jump
and so in in the video you know i'm
paraphrasing just like so we can get it
all out there for the audio but if
you're not watching on audio there's
this hill that you know doe brick
launched his testimony for you know i've
driven over the street a bunch of times
where is it oh it's on the east side
okay so this dude comes with a car meet
in a what looks like a brand new black
model x or not model x the what's the
other one
model s
and he just goes
watch this basically just like hold my
beer and then this and let it play
i love you can hear the pick up on the
test later
up and over
bro
on alex choi's youtube like the youtube
video he made about look it up i don't
want to like i don't want to like steal
views from his [ __ ] but there's a frame
after the car gets launched where alex
is just yeah dude
what the [ __ ] bro
let it's okay it's launched over let it
run
that
he's just like
actually okay we can play the first five
seconds the silence after the guy like
goes in the air
and everyone's just [ __ ] staring
they're like um
it's it's dead silent it's the it's the
hang time before the car connects to the
pavement they're all like
did you see the car after
yeah so in this video it shows it it's
it is both airbags right it's perfectly
fine
no it's not [ __ ] you
did they interview the guy who did it
nah nah that dude have like nobody knows
no that must have been a whole thing he
must have got that [ __ ] towed and first
of all he annihilates a trash can which
is just it's just not it's funny like
it's definitely funny it's funny because
there wasn't any cars or anything there
was down the street but like he hits
that car oh it did he yeah it's a car at
the bottom of the hill parked car it's
gonna need a new rear bumper but other
than that i thought this the back of
this car was gonna be totaled can you
imagine
having a knock on that dude's door yeah
hey bro sorry i am so first of all
check this video out yes
that's pretty [ __ ] crazy right that's
like one of the craziest videos you've
ever seen as you're bleeding from yeah
exactly all the way down your face yeah
looking like [ __ ] look up what's his
face from doom 2 when he's all beat like
busted the [ __ ] up
when you have like 10 health
yeah
it's just a [ __ ] eating grin
bloody tail
all right dude what's up he's sick right
pretty sick right you have no front
teeth yeah
that was sick right well that was me
just now right over there and here's the
thing yeah you thought the video was
cool right it's it's good that this
video exists right okay so there ha
there was some collateral damage
unfortunately dude i just totaled your
ford explorer so you're not going to
work tomorrow but
we'll be on the news it's going to be
viral
god damn man i just love how when it
gets in the air that moment where
it's just oh
this isn't gonna work
and the dude said
in alex's video he's quoting him the guy
says
well
uh i guess the guy said he's done i
don't know if he's done it before but he
said something to the effect of he had
more he had more people in the car so he
decided to give it a little more
throttle
oh there was multiple people
not only that bro if there was anything
else in this car that could make this
clip feel that much worse what would you
guess it would be
there was a child in the car close there
was a puppy in the car it was a cat ah
the cat's fine everyone's fine there's
something about like the cat was given
to him that day like they like adopted
it or something and then he just did
that with some people in the car and a
[ __ ] cat
dude is so lucky
a bunch of people you know granted it
was reddit so
you gotta read it with your front teeth
out but a lot of the comments were like
this dude's so lucky because electrical
fires and specifically like
tesla batteries this uh such decent
probability that he would have hit that
ford explorer and that [ __ ] would have
just gone boom
really yeah jesus christ but he didn't
because elon builds literally the best
card
that's the worst part about this clip is
this [ __ ] happen and every [ __ ] tesla
nerd
like
did you see the guy who did the front
slip and his in his model and survived
it's totally fine better engineering
than most other modern cars out there
yeah that's the worst thing to come out
of all this is this is going to give
confidence to tesla owners that don't
deserve it
100 dude look at how high it is
that's like 20 that's like 15 feet in
the air
is it not
look at those five frames yo back that
up and then run it again
like with the keyboard like with the
arrow keys it doesn't look that crazy
and then the road
the road goes down so fast it's just
like
[Laughter]
are you kidding me it's [ __ ] it's a
spaceship for those [ __ ]
two seconds
dude
alex left the top comment on this to
have me rolling it was like yo this
spacex thing is working pretty good
[Laughter]
oh my god man
imagine like it didn't like that could
have been so bad it wasn't
like forget an electrical fire yeah it
just barely like didn't hit and rolled
over the other way
then what do you do you can't stop so
you're just listening
or just like at the top like something
like causes it to rotate yes something
dude
just something
that face is so good
yeah
expressionless bro
it just [ __ ]
you're probably gonna die yeah dude
oh god damn man
is that a cctv camp i think that
someone's like
like dash cam yeah that's funny are we
in the bonus now by the way we kind of
are thanks for watching today guy yeah
let's go in the bone zone thanks guys we
got so much coming up in the bone zone
what do we got let's get a quick look at
the list
cody gets four fingers in his mouth
you